Denver Nuggets Governor Stan kroenke has
now won his fifth championship in 18
months he owns a 12.8 billion dollar
successful Sports Empire let's break
down all of his W's throughout the past
year and a half Stan's nuggets secured
their first ever NBA Finals Victory he
owns the Colorado Avalanche who won the
Stanley Cup last year and that happened
right after the LA Rams beat the Bengals
in Super Bowl 56. Stan also has a
lacrosse team the Colorado Mammoth who
won the national lacrosse Cup in 2022.
I'm not done his Esports team the Los
Angeles gorillas secured the title in
the Call of Duty League last year as
well one of the only teams he owns that
hasn't copped a victory yet is Arsenal
and although they did just have one of
their best seasons finishing Five Points
behind Champions Manchester City second
place just isn't good enough for Stan